[Applause]
all right so after this giant mess in
afghanistan
what's the response from the white house
boy did we screw up but look how we
fixed it
and talk about fixed this is a mess so
screwed up it will have reverberations
for many years which means the person
responsible probably won't see the end
results but still the white house will
say
look at this humanitarian feat of
strength it's more impressive than joe
protecting us from corn pop
but we got out a hundred thousand plus
people before the deadline the taliban
wanted yeah spirit airline has nothing
on us
it's a weird contrast on one hand we're
evacuating thousands of afghans on the
other we say the taliban's changed so
why is everyone fleeing if they changed
so do we have anything to fear from the
taliban other than their fashion sense
they're new and improved like an apache
helicopter we left behind
sure they just banned music and killed a
folk singer it's the terror version of
footloose
i guess the taliban prefers their
pleasing sounds to come from goats
so are things changing well check out
this anchorman reading the news
their taliban sensors don't even bother
to stand off camera you can tell the
anchor's really looking forward to a
bright future under his new leaders
here's a tip buddy don't play any music
this ain't cnn where when you screw up
you get a vacation
but i'm not one to point fingers
or am i
greg points the fingers
starring fingers
[Music]
yes it's time once again to point
fingers after all that's why we have
them it's why humans are in charge
instead of seals
they don't have fingers emily
they have fins
people say greg it's too soon for that
that's what they said about the premiere
of this show and i didn't listen but if
we weren't calling out this bs then who
will and think of all the great finger
pointers in history
some of our greatest coaches pointed
fingers
those are coaches so did every member of
the four tops
your mom at the aquarium look a whale a
whale
every doctor about to do a prostate exam
even the image is arousing and let's not
forget everyone's favorite alien that's
right he pointed a finger
and what of uncle sam a great finger
pointer and of course the greatest
finger pointer of all
god
so back to this mess you only deserve
credit if you do a thorough job of
cleaning it up but if you left hundreds
of americans behind you didn't clean it
up it's like how a guy cleans up after
an all-night poker game you threw out
the beer bottles into pizza boxes and
say you're good now you still got to get
all those stains out of the rug before
your wife gets home or at least move the
sofa over it this isn't nitpicking this
is about american lives
and if you left them behind you gotta
fix it and maybe our government is and
not telling us fine but consider the
people in charge
the ones who have a history of snatching
defeat from the jaws of victory no one's
blaming the troops who don't make the
decisions and are in danger we're
blaming the politicians who made
decisions and then went on vacation
meanwhile the white house and the media
will redefine your outrage against biden
as directed against the military
if you're mad about the disastrous pull
out joe pretends you're mad that we're
ending a war his entire speech was bait
and switch i love how he brags about the
withdrawal while also blaming trump
so it's a success unless it's a failure
and then that's on trump no the decision
made by trump was pretty sound it's
biden's follow-through
follow-through that we're all pissed off
about
and we aren't pissed at the military
except for generals pushing wokeness
while saying the taliban has no chance
we're upset with the administration who
like a drunk hiker lost in the woods
chose the worst possible path and put
everyone at risk
looking back it takes a specific genius
to make that many mistakes it's like
flipping a coin and getting heads 100
times in a row how can you be that
consistent it's impossible for things to
go wrong this perfectly unless it was
baked into the plan you abandon an air
base before evacuating americans you
hand over a pile of weaponry to our
enemies making the taliban better armed
than the nra
you have the president telling us
everything would be fine knock on wood
yeah knock on wood only if you can find
john kerry's face
talk about a drastic escalation in the
use of knock-on wood usually i say that
for hoping the cafeteria still has soup
then you see afghans falling from planes
but hey that was five days ago remember
that so a hundred times shorter than
russiagate an amazing answer one i
wouldn't use when you're arrested or
caught cheating on your spouse
then we give a list of americans to the
taliban i'm still unsure what that means
but i doubt they're going to become pen
pals
then we get 13 dead from a homicidal
bomber who was checking that bomber in
was it the taliban it matters when you
then hear that they offered control of
kabul to biden who declined it he
probably thought hell i can't control my
eyelids how am i going to control an
airport
so he wanted the taliban to have more
control of afghanistan than the taliban
wanted
and then as the caskets of our dead were
unloaded from a plane at dover air force
base
joe biden checked his watch
he took 36 hours to call back boris
johnson but suddenly he's in a hurry
look i won't point any fingers here
because if i were joe biden i'd be
checking my watch too how much longer do
i have to do this job he's wondering
believe me so are we
[Applause]
tonight's guest
she talks faster than an auctioneer who
has to pee outnumber co-host emily
compagno
the buck stopped here and he brought his
hair radio host buck sexton
[Applause]
he's got a face for radio and a wardrobe
for the blind fox news radio host jimmy
failure
and she's like lance armstrong really
successful but cheats on drug tests
fox's contributor cat tip
all right buck i'm going to go to you
first because you served in the cia in
afghanistan and your hair served in nam
right
i'm world war yes so what do you make of
this botched
this botched whatever you want to call
it well we're saying it's botched now
because it is and we saw it and they
couldn't hide it from us in part because
the taliban doesn't have the technology
or the ability to shut down people were
texting me in real time about what was
going on on the ground there they were
sending photos around so we saw what a
mess it was it was clearly not planned
but just give this a few days right
because now that we're at the point
where we're out now there's still a
hundred plus americans on the ground the
narrative is going to switch very
quickly to joe biden is the guy that got
things done he's the one that made the
tough call here and the fact that they
were talking about a 300 000 person plus
army that evaporated that we lost
soldiers in afgh in afghanistan that we
had all the disasters we've seen will be
quickly forgotten and they're already
you started to see some blips on cnn
about the insurrection commission right
now they're subpoenaing the trump family
records they're going to move past this
as quickly as possible and the new
narrative is going to be gaslighting on
a a thermonuclear scale it'll be the
moab of gaslighting from the biden
administration
um you're in the cia how did
we get i love the fact that joe biden
will get accolades after being a vp for
eight years while uh you know presiding
over afghanistan but why was he why was
the intelligence so wrong
well because the people in the
intelligence community who tell those in
charge what they want to hear are the
ones who get to keep talking to the
people in charge the ones that get into
the oval office the ones that write for
the for the pdb regularly it's just like
every other bureaucracy or corporate you
know the the butt kissers essentially
get promoted and move up and the good
people often feel like they can't handle
it until they leave and get on late
night tv that's what happens
was that a jab at your own self
something like that yes yes yes i know
but you're right it's like it's inside
every massive major project you need to
make it sound like it's going well
emily so that they don't stop the
project so you find data that supports
it for example you know they sabotaged
27 humvees and they don't forget to tell
you there were like 27 000 of them or
something like that what do you mean
where do you where does your brain rest
at this point
well
look bottom line we have a
commander-in-chief who abandoned
americans he abandoned allies
and orphans and women and working dogs
to meet an arbitrary deadline that he
set
he surrendered all of these lives and
like billions of dollars worth of
equipment to the taliban
and
had the audacity
to do a victory lap today
touting it as this amazing you know
airlift is happening the airlift occurs
after a hurricane it doesn't occur in
the vacuum of a taliban takeover that
you created he blamed everyone else on
the planet but himself including our
afghan allies who lost 66 000 of their
own people alongside our 2500 and then
we lost 13 more under his watch and then
speaking of watch as you pointed out he
checks his watch each time a coffin
comes out of the plane during a
dignified transfer
and we are supposed to think that this
person has the the gravitas the the
anything the modicum of responsibility
needed to hold this office so to me on
this final day of a 20-year war
other than
endless gratitude for everyone who
served
and honoring every life who was
sacrificed who did not die in vain
during those 20 years i personally feel
nothing but ashamed that that person is
my president
strong emotion
now
jimmy
your jacket is almost as bad as a
withdrawal
but i like how you matched your shoes
with that
i committed yeah go all the way in
where's the ice cream truck it's around
the block yeah you didn't tell me biden
was going to be here that was the ice
cream
i do feel on some level you guys are
being a little harsh to joe biden if you
take like a 20 000 foot view of this i
mean other than foreign policy covert
the border inflation gas prices unity
race relations the guy's doing a pretty
good job
other than everything in the country the
guy's done a great job now this is
embarrassing and the brazen nature in
which they lie to the public
it's all it really does bother me
because on some level they're talking to
us as if we'll forget number one which
is pretty condescending and number two
they're doing it with the assumption
that the media is always going to be
there for them and we have learned that
the media did try to create some
distance between themselves and this
because it was horrific but it didn't
stop them from doing what they do like
jen saki gets out there every day if gen
saki did press for the titanic she would
blame the iceberg on climate change and
tell you the evacuation went great yes
it's like everybody's fine other than
leonardo dicaprio he's dead over there
and there's no preconditions with the
iceberg no no you don't have to
negotiate we're talking about the
iceberg right now
uh we're gonna like you know we're gonna
get yeah i'm gonna just stop that joke
there but i know but to one point of the
whole thing um and you were saying this
earlier about the habit both ways
mentality of biden okay on one end he
wants you to believe it was successful
on the other end yes he wants you to
believe this is what trump did now if
that is to be the case we're going to
take him at his word joe biden has
rescinded every one of donald trump's
policies through executive order why is
this the one policy he kept right if it
was so bad exactly okay he screwed this
up joe biden sucks bottom line no but
that is such a great point
[Applause]
jimmy just succeeded emily on red meat
points by saying that that's true yeah
so uh cat it's good to i'm i'm glad that
hot topic was open today and you're able
to get your outfit i look so i look so
good
i look really really good thank you she
does know
and i just want to be clear it was
forever 31.
oh my god you guys no you look amazing
it looks great you know jimmy you're
right you're far more attractive than i
am
oh you got this you won that race this
is the kind of debate we need to be
having
you're slightly more attractive than
jimmy
well now you're fired
damn it i walked right into that she set
us up all right we're not airing this
episode oh
all right i looked so good
aside from how breathtakingly attractive
that i am
uh yeah this is horrible the whole
speech was about how we can't nation
build which is something i agree with
right but that's also something that
i've always believed which is very
opposite to joe biden's you know
decades-long campaign for nation
building when did he change he maybe had
something to do with it there and i just
i agree with buck i wanna i would love
to see a couple people get fired because
we can't nation build doesn't work we
knew that sooner than 20 years so who
are all these yes men they're at the
heads of all these companies defense
companies they're on tv telling us what
we should do
i'd like to see them get fired and we
cancel people for literally everything
else except stuff that really matters so
let's cancel some of these people was in
afghanistan ten years ago every senior
level military and bureaucrat and the
federal government you talked to was
like we figured it out we've got it we
know the next 12 months and every person
you talked to who was on their fifth
tour or their seventh tour and knew the
country all said no chance yes exactly
no chance that was a decade ago that is
so depressing when you think about the
amount of lives and blood treasure lost
in 10 years it's it makes you sick to
your stomach hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else